aujourd'hui c'est en voisin que nous
recevons emmanuel ungaro est sa boutique
en effet est à deux portes d'antenne 2
avenue montaigne
une collection superbe c'est ce que m'a
dit oh bah grégoire une collection qui
était présenté justement ce matin alors
emmanuel ungaro on va voir tout à
l'heure quelques images de cette
collection simplement une question
préalable votre inspiration cette année
quelque chose de particulier enfin un
thème particulier il n'est jamais venu
il ya simplement la poursuite effrénée
passionnés danse du même discours
amoureux c'est à dire que les j'exerce
ce métier depuis si longtemps et j'aime
l'exercer et j'ai voulu dit n'avoir
donné à voir véritablement ce qu'est ce
métier quelle est l'essence de ce métier
cette même façon de progresser à travers
cet univers qui n'est pas un humain
fut-il du tout il va très beau qui peut
être plein d'émotions open poésie en
tout cas votre collection été très bien
accueilli ce maintenant je vous propose
tout de suite avec un reportage
un reportage de philippe baron de voir
les images de votre collection et vous
allez les commenter alors tout de suite
les images donc de cette collection
ungaro c'était ce matin
j contre tout de lui
wild en longueur se situe du genou si
c'est si c'est comme ça pour expliquer
les choses mais ce qui peut expliquer
surtout c'est l'élégance et la
purification et la recherche
vérifications dans les formes inquiète
pas essentiel voilà des robes qui sont
en fait la traduction de ce que nous les
importantes du costume d'homme
finalement traités avec une désinvolture
et avec une liste de recherche d'
équilibre à travers les épaules les
hanches qui sont très importantes la
revue avait évidemment
est ce qu'il ya des pantalons dans votre
élection à peut-être à voir avec
seulement peu cette année ça revient
petit peu à la mode n'est pas chez vous
la département ne compte pas beaucoup
enfin en tout cas pour moi c'est par
l'importance et d'exprimer 7,7 et
féminité
cette sensualité et cette liquidité qui
s'exprime parfaitement à travers
l'europe nous devons maintenant beaucoup
de gris de noir il ya le gris d'argent
j'ai mes traités dans le temps l'argent
justement il n'y a pas ce n'est pas un
gris tristes et là vous avez tout un
tableau de d'ensemble rose et noir qui a
voulu être vraiment un poème en fait on
parle toujours des longueurs on parle
par exemple cette année de la mode des
pantalons continue à voir des images ça
ce sont les robes de soirée vous avez
l'impression qu'il y a qu il ya toujours
les mêmes tendances qui reviennent chez
les couturiers chaque année enfin les
tendances plus profond à ce que vous
donnez le mot un petit peu sinon pas je
crois que les couturiers qui compte ont
un style et je vois le sigui part
essentielle de caden broeck à 6 de
demeurer fidèle à moi même si sa saison
et ça fait vous êtes installé à paris
depuis soixante-cinq je crois donc ça
fait un moment que les aventuriers connu
comment vous jugez vos jeunes confrères
qui s'installe ce sont des concurrents
d'abord mais ce sont des concurrents et
heureusement ce sont des gens qui a
beaucoup de talent il est heureux que
dans ce métier
d'autres talents s'installe diane et
nous dit tim hamsik et être extrêmement
intéressant mais reste à prouver parce
que finalement l'important c'est de
durer dans ce métier ne ce n'est pas
simple de fans collection c'est dans
tous les métiers comme ça vous savez
mais certainement la route
j'ai entendu dire aussi que à paris dans
les soirées très élégante
les modèles qu'on voyait le plus c'était
les modèles d'une gare où vous aviez la
plus belle clientèle parisienne c'est
vrai je rejoue vous l'entendez monsieur
vous l'a dit c'est pour le moment
vraiment une n'y est pas en tout cas je
ne le nie sûrement pas oui est ce que ça
veut dire que vous travaillez peut-être
moins pour l'exportation
non absolument pas non il faut dire que
l'exportation est du domaine du
prêt-à-porter
là nous sommes dans le domaine de la
haute couture évidemment il ya un nombre
de clients est extrêmement privilégiés
qui ont la chance
voire de s'habiller en disant des
vêtements de haute couture mais on dit
justement que au moyen-orient les pétro
dollars soit - nombre sont moins
nombreux est-ce que sur la mode ça se
ressent ce jeu n'est pas juste ce
sentiment en ma clientèle
en tout cas n'est pas du tout orienté
vers ce genre de situation et fait une
clientèle étrangère surtout américaines
surtout aux amériques n'est absolument
merci emmanuel ungaro
merci donc d'être venu aujourd'hui nous
avoir présenté votre collection
[Musique]